ça lui fait ériger le terme est ainsi
une chambre sur le campus de saclay
j'étais plié ton pantalon alors sous
préfète ou alors remarqué déconne grave
ma grande tu dois laisser boire de l'eau
dans son vin super ça m'aide beaucoup
sa part à la fête ce soir un combat je
vois les anniversaires
la salle est terminée
[Musique]
écoute je sais que ça va de bart est
complètement perdue contre le
réchauffement climatique n'ont plus rien
que ce train de vous paraît alors là tu
déconnes grave ma grande joie news
anniversaire j'ai déjà vécu deux
journées
allez vas-y
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
même en partant du principe que c'est
possible
arrosage automatique alors c'est ce que
j'en pense moi je pense que tu as un
nombre de vies il est autant d'occasions
de résoudre ton propre merde donc juste
ans et continuer à mourir
jusqu'à ce que je découvre qu'il est mon
as tu veux vivre jusqu'à demain non
c'est lui qui te tue il sait que c'est
ton anniversaire en gros tout la pac est
courante vous avez subi des traumatismes
très grave vous devriez être morte
quand on revit la même journée en boucle
on commence à savoir qui en est vraiment